For the past few questions, we've looked at equations that we can treat as
linear equations, up to a certain point, of course. But we spent a bunch of
time in this course, also talking about quadratic equations. And in fact, we're
going to need to use those techniques as well for certain equations that use
exponents. Let's look at example of one of those right now. Here we have e to
the 2x minus 5e to the x plus 6 equals 0. Now, it might not look like it right
away, but this is actually a quadratic equation in e to the x. To see this more
clearly, let's make a little substitution. Let's let u equal e to the x. How
then, would you rewrite the first 2 terms of our equation in terms of u? Please
fill in these pink spots with the proper numbers, variables, or expressions.